so recently a four-year-old kid got into
a gorilla enclosure in a zoo and the zoo
officials decided in the safety of the
kid they had to kill the gorilla so here
was an animal that was in his natural
habitat in Africa doing his gorilla
tackle thing and he got captured and
ended up in a zoo and then the guy got
shot for because some kid crawled into
his enclosure it's just there's no good
thing about this with that said my life
was certainly enriched by going to zoos
I look I learned that even that a
giraffe could exist was an amazing thing
to me and the smell of the zoo was or is
something I'll never forget and reminds
me of farms there's animal excrement
that's be dealt with and you see how
much you have in common with these
creatures is it ethical I think we all
agree be better now if we didn't have
zoos if we had a way to interact with
animals without causing them such
hardship and the example from my
personal experience which really affects
me it affects my judgment on this there
was a guy named Ivan who was a gorilla
brought the United States in the 1960s
my recollection is 1962 and he lived
with a family in Tacoma Washington and
they hung out the gorilla was at the
dinner table and they did gorilla humic
human interaction things played games
did stuff but the guy eventually got to
be the 400-pound gorilla in the room and
they had to put him in a enclosure in a
cage that was concrete and you could
visit him in the BNI department store in
Tacoma Washington and this in the
Pacific Northwest this guy was a care
a character a feature a tourist
attraction and I don't know I'm not a
primate expert but I looked at Ivan I
looked him in the eye when we had a
little meeting behind the glass and the
guy wasn't angry to me so much his board
like this sucks you know I got a rubber
swing that's just the humans are
interesting but it's really not my deal
he got transferred to the Atlanta zoo
and I visited him in the Atlanta zoo and
he had it going on man he had a big
enclosure
he had girl gorillas and you could just
tell by the way he was walking around
this does not suck this is cool you know
that was my interpretation of Ivan's
emotions I may be completely wrong about
this but Ivan grew up with humans he
accepted humans humans were as much his
pets as he was our pet and so there was
some crossover there that I found really
compelling as a human
now there's another guy who's in the
Seattle zoo the Woodland Park Zoo and
his name's VIP very important person VIP
and when you look at VIP he's looking at
you okay human this kind of sucks you
are a skinny nothing and I could reach
in there and I could strangle you and I
could wake you over my knee right now
you know what else I'm a vegetarian yet
I want to mess you up because he can
just tell that something went wrong his
people are huge they're living in a
forest they had it going on and now
they're stuck in this glass enclosure
there's a lot of room I guess there's a
waterfall or whatever but this is not
what I had in mind growing up so there's
these two gorillas have had a deep
effect on my perception if we had a way
to interact with these creatures without
causing them hardship it would be cool
and I will say as a kid my life was
enriched by visiting
so I people have got to think this
through and I'd say right now thinking
about it it seems like a humane
enclosures where the animals don't have
two fates don't have to face predators
don't have to have their offspring eaten
by literally by lions or dogs that's not
bad but causing him hardship and
shooting this guy this is really
troubling should the parents be sued my
brother who has four raised four
children just rails all the time about
parents who are not attentive parents
who leave their kids unattended so
there's something to that should that
parent and that child pay the ultimate
price for this transgression of the zoo
enclosure not being four year old proof
man there is not a clear-cut answer but
I hope we all learn from this make the
enclosures robust the enclosures that
exist now let us all rethink about the
ethics of in of confining these primates
that were so close to and let us promote
diversity one of the great things that
may come from modern zoos is the ability
to reintroduce these animals in the
ecosystem and another example that's on
my mind for everybody for you to think
about before we move away from this
topic apparently using satellite imagery
and Park Rangers experience walking
around on the ground in Yellowstone Park
Service Rangers and officials noticed
that there were very few young trees
growing along the banks of streams in
Yellowstone and then wolves were
reintroduced from a humane standpoint
your wolves are part of the ecosystem
why should we always be shooting wolves
or catching wolves and killing them and
making wolf rugs or whatever we would do
and when the wolves were reintroduced
young trees appeared again
because the wolves were predated were
eating the elk that would eat the young
shoots of the trees when the trees would
grow along the banks of the streams you
would not think right away if you want
more trees bring in wolves but that is
apparently what happened ecosystems are
very complicated so the more diversity
we can induce or reintroduce into
ecosystems the better so there's
reasonable to me that zoos have a role
in reintroducing megafauna big animals
it's very reasonable but the kid getting
in the enclosure and shooting the
gorillas that is a lose-lose negotiation
I hope we all feel bad about that